What are the dangers of using a stat drug to lower cholesterol, especially with the kids or diagnosis?
The stat drugs do lower cholesterol. You can't argue with that. However, they also do all sorts of
damage to the liver itself. And there are long-term studies, and I didn't pull any of them up,
there are long-term studies showing that people taking a stat into lower cholesterol really don't
have any better outcomes as far as reducing coronary artery disease or having any type of
mild lesser incidence of myocardial infarction. Just because you could alter a blood value
with a drug doesn't mean that you leave a patient any healthy. So I'll say it again, just because
you could use a drug to change the value of a blood marker, to put it back into more normal range,
doesn't mean that you've actually made a healthier patient. So be careful about that. It's just like
that with prostate cancer, they have an elevated PSA. You go on energy deprivation therapy.
I'll guarantee you that at least for a couple of years, your PSA is going to be a normal range.
But don't be fool to think that that has solved your problem and your cancer is gone.
You've just lowered the PSA marker artificially by taking a medication you've necessarily reduced
that person's chance of metastasis or increase their life expectancy.
If you're really just solely concerned about getting a blood marker back in normal levels,
just crossing out on your blood test and just write a normal level in there if that makes you feel
better. What are you talking about? That's absolutely getting out. That's what we're doing by just
using medication to get the marker back into lower level. And it's far less destructive because
you crossing it out on your blood test doesn't have any side effects. But I'd rather not have you do
either one of those things. The smarter thing to do is try to figure out why. Now sometimes cholesterol
as a marker is difficult because some people can have a elevated cholesterol that is
hereditary. You can have hereditary factors that you have hyperclestrolemia and that you can't
really do anything to lower it. Some people have a perfect diet, they're doing everything perfect
and they still have elevated cholesterol. Maybe that's just normal for them. You know, understand
values. It's like normal temperatures, 98.6. Well, some people's normal temperature is 96.6.
And some people's normal temperature is 99.6. That normal temperature is just, you know, the
average human race that has been tested. So sometimes you can do everything right and you can't
get your certain levels back into normal. Is that increasing your risk for different things?
Maybe, but I don't see that using a medication that could have other side effects is the
smart thing to do. Do you know, is there a greater risk with a stat growing with a cancer patient?
Now, I don't think there's any greater risk with a stat growing with the cancer patient,
unless they also have liver cancer. But I haven't seen any data in there.